for those of you survivors who don't
know already Daisy just got a little bit
meteor februari brings us a new patch
with some fairly significant
improvements that make life in turn Obol
not necessarily easier but more
enjoyable if you're an avid daisy player
a couple of these updates will
definitely affect your gameplay so
without do here's the rundown let's
start small and cute and learn our new
gestures f5 is for clapping as in Bravo
zombie I love the way you dance f6 is
for pointing as in hey there
good-looking military zombies have made
it through boot camp and they are pissed
off they have improved durability and
tougher attack value so look out you
also get a new weapon machete and how
about some crafting canned food can now
be opened with the combat knife and
machete you can now also backwash water
with friends with the ability to
transfer water between canteens and
water bottles new effects are added to
the revolver and mosin so that sound
effects and reload animations looking
good and lastly a couple of game
changers in my opinion you now can get
up to a five minute time out if you
change between servers if you've played
on a server for under 30 minutes but
probably the biggest change goes out to
all you cowardly combat loggers upon
disconnecting your avatar will sit down
requiring a 30 second period for it to
leave the server meaning it is
imperative you find a safe place to sign
out those are just a few of the patch
notes but check out the link in the
description if you'd like to see more
thanks for watching see you next time
you